one of the things that's causing this
funk that people are in is that we're
living our lives and these are very
unfulfilled ways where you're going to
this office with artificial light and
you're doing something you don't want to
do all day long and then you get home
and you're tired and on top of that
you're eating potato chips and you're
drinking soda and your body is just like
what is this we're supposed to be out in
the fields we're supposed to be walking
up hills we're supposed to be looking
for animals or gathering vegetables
we're supposed to be doing all these
things that our body is designed to do
we're supposed to be in nature and
nature is like a medicine like it
literally is a medicine to you you don't
have to go hunting you don't have to go
fishing just go for the hike man just go
hike up to the top of a mountain and
look out you know there's a reward that
you get from that that is intensely soul
filling you should always be seeking to
improve the connection with human beings
on a very positive level where you build
up like a trust and you you have a
warmth and friendship and you root for
each other and you you share in each
other's bounty and you you build
together we all know inherently in our
heads that kindness is one of the best
gifts you can bestow another human being
whatever the fit is we know that
inherently that feels great and we know
it we have to figure out how to use our
resources together so that we can be
like that all the time I think it's
always about doing what you actually
want to be doing with your life there's
a lot of people that we always wanted to
be singers and they just for whatever
reason never pursued it yeah so they
just sing around their house and they
always wonder what could have been a
biggest tribe to be a singing that's one
a form of a roadblock in your life the
depressed feeling that you didn't try
you didn't try to reach your potential
hmm you didn't go after what is
intriguing to you like we all have
almost like a beacon that it pulls us in
a certain direction the happiness that's
involved in pursuing your your inherent
desires is the unavoidable in a career
but I guarantee you there's one out
there that you really really want to do
you just watched two amazing clips from
Joe Rogan take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you